رسميا في اسرائيل ما يزال الصمت المطبق هو
سيد الموقف بهذا الشان كما كان في مرات
عديده سابقه لكن ما يجري هو ان وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه وتحديدا المراسلين
للشؤون العسكريه والامنيه والذين غالبا ما
يكونوا مرتبطين بالجهات الامنيه
الاسرائيليه يكثرون من الحديث عن ان هناك
شخصيه كبيره ايضا من الجهاد الاسلامي قد
كان
مكن اسمحي ان اتابع معكم هذا الخبر العاجل
نقلا عن رويترز مقتل اربعه من الحرس
الثوري الايراني اذا بينهم رئيس وحده
المعلومات في غاره جويه اسرائيليه على
دمشق نعيد ونكرر مقتل اربعه اذا من الحرس
الثوري الايراني بينهم رئيس وحده
المعلومات في غاره جويه اسرائيليه على
دمشق هذا ما اعلنته رويترز وليد
العمري
نعم ويشار في هذا السياق ايضا الى انه قبل
نحو شهر وفي ساحه السيده زينب في دمشق
اغتالت اسرائيل مسؤولا كبيرا جدا من الحرس
الثوري الايراني في حينه وهو رضا موسوي
وهي عمليه متواصله لكن هذه المره التزمت
الصمت كعادتها ووسائلها الاعلاميه تحاول
ان تروج ايضا عن ان هناك جهات اخرى
مستهدفه كانت في هذا المبنى وتذكر كثيرا
شخصيات كبيره من حركه الجهاد الاسلامي على
وجه الخصوص وواضح بانها ايضا تحاول ان
تشير في بعض الاحيان وكان هناك رد
اسرائيلي على ما كان قد تعرض له موقع في
اربيل قيل بانه يتبع للموساد الاسرائيلي
وقصف بالصواريخ من ايران لكن الكثير من
الغموض يكتنف التفاصيل والحقائق حول كل
هذا التسلسل لعمليات الاغتيال ما جرى
اليوم في حي المزه في دمشق وهو قصف لمبنى
واسقاطه المصادر التي يرشح عنها المعلومات
تقول انه كان قصفا جويا وقد تسبب بانهيار
المبنى باكمله وليس واضحا عدد الذين قتلوا
سواء الحديث عن اربعه اشخاص وقيل ان
جثامينهم قد تفحمت جراء هذا القصف في جميع
الاحوال
الاسرائيليون كانوا قد استهدفوا وما زالوا
قيادات كبيره من الجهاد الاسلامي اكثرهم
يذكرون بالاسماء دائما الشيخ اكرم العجوري
الذي كان قد تعرض منزله ايضا للقصف
واستشهد في حينه نجله في عام في فبراير من
عام 20 من عام 20 وقبل ذلك ايضا استهدف
وكان واضحه من قبل اسرائيل في ال من اغسطس
عام 22 وفي ال عش من فبراير عام 23 ايضا
كان مستهدفا في دمشق كل هذه المحاولات
باءت بالفشل ولم يصلوا اليه لكن هذا جاء
ضمن تسلسل عمليات اغتيال بداتها اسرائيل
في الثان ع من نوفمبر عام
2019 عندما بدات باغتيال القائد العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي في غزه بهاء ابو العطا
الان كما قلت الكثير من الغموض يكتف كل
هذه المعلومات ليس واضحا ما اذام هو كان
مستهد كان موجودا ام كان مستهدفا لكن
المبنى الذي ضرب يبدو ان اسرائيل تعيره
اهميه كبيره او ترى ان من تواجد في داخله
من الشخصيات الوازن فيما يعرف بمحور
المقاومه